if you're addicted to water you are the
most boring person in the world
you
you need help if it's something just
say water
how about then has that has that been a
notified addiction yeah so I've seen one
case of that in my career um it was
actually very sad it was a woman with a
very severe alcohol addiction who got
into recovery from her alcohol addiction
but somehow or another she discovered
that if she drank water in copious
amounts she could feel altered and she
got addicted to that process and
ultimately she had several severe
episodes of hyponatremia and then almost
died from those episodes holy crap I was
only joking now I feel like a jackass no
no it's okay that's right but